hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
when h1z1 made it over to ps4 1.5
million of us tried it on the first day
alone and now almost 5 million players
have downloaded the og battle royale
title so what do you think of hitch one
z1 we have to keep in mind that it's
still in beta status of beta status
which is improving and evolving each
week let's look into the future of the
game and see what new things are coming
to h1z1 on PlayStation 4 new game modes
and playlist will slowly be added over
the next year there's already a
blueprint in place following the
structure of the PC version the autorai
game-mode looks insane it changes things
up by stopping any feet from actually
touching the ground instead each team
has a vehicle and searches for power-ups
before attempting to shoot the
opposition and run them off the road the
power-ups include oil slicks to cause
your phones to lose control completely
and there's even a landmine to auto
Royale offers a break from the try-hard
nature of the battle royale mode with
more action - another game mode which
will eventually come over to ps4 is
weapon roulette which sees everyone
start with a random weapon and unlimited
ammo as time goes by the gun in your
possession is randomly switched forcing
each of us to play in different ways to
get used to each weapon as well as huge
big updates like that there are small
improvements which will make a huge
difference
centered around controller options the
hair trigger has been improved allowing
us to press a little lighter when firing
but the entire controller layout will be
improved in future updates if you're a
person who prefers to crouch using the
right thumbstick that fix should soon be
here personally I'm hoping for a control
method closer to combat pro in quanta
cycling through weapons with r1 and l1
suits me and I find that the current
differences in layout between h1z1 and
fortnight prevent me from dedicating
more time to h1z1 in fear of losing the
muscle memory or tonight that's only one
man's opinion of course how would you
improve the controls in h1z1
staying on the theme of controller
opportunities an update will be coming
soon which will allow for improved aim
acceleration and custom sensitivity
options which are a little bit below par
at present the weapon wheel is set to
get an upgrade allowing us to pick and
choose which slots we use for each
weapon at present we must throw our
weapons on the ground and then pick them
up in a certain order to keep them that
way in terms of becoming a better player
we need to have control over our weapons
for example always knowing your trusty
shotgun is in slot 2 we'll make
split-second decisions a little bit
easier
the revive mechanic is on its way it may
already be in the game when you're
watching this this will obviously only
be available in squads and duo's but
offers a second chance to be brought
back into the game if you've taken a
stray bullet to the head no one likes
being killed at the start of the game
and waiting for the rest of the match
unless they win it and carry you to
victory now that is fine
[Music]
[Applause]
daily challenges will soon be expanded
upon to mirror those on PC has a random
example playing the heavy-metal event on
PC NetID players weekend rewards
including this piece of sexy body armor
of course there'll be loot which
requires real-world money
this is afraid to play game so they need
to make money someway but it's good to
know that everyone won't be stuck with
the exact same skins if they play more
often over two new items now and you may
already know that the new EMP grenade
will be added to h1z1 allowing us to
stop vehicles and force those car
campers to get involved in the action
eventually the vehicles will begin to
work again but there'll be a window of
opportunity to get the upper hand if
we're lucky we may see the fortnight
approach to community relations which
sees constant adding and removing of
content to keep the game feeling fresh
and mixing up the meta also expect
weapon rebalancing so maybe that trash
ak-47 will be useful in the future Oh
another new toy we'll be getting our
hands on soon is the airstrike for added
explosions come on who doesn't love a
good explosion and finally framerate
improvements are on the way to hit 60
frames per second on console is no easy
achievement at present the ps4 pro
almost hit 60 frames a second with
analysis reporting the average number to
be around 50 to 55 but the standard ps4
can only achieve around 45 frames per
second depending on how many things are
blowing up on screen
amongst other things this will give a
slight advantage to ps4 pro players in
split-second decision-making especially
in close combat
but as h1z1 has a longer time to kill
than most first person shooters or
battle royale games this advantage to
pro players isn't as game breaking as it
seems
rest assured though behind the scenes
the h1z1 devs continue to optimize the
game rebalancing visuals against
framerate so there we have it a wait
h1z1 will continue to improve over the
next few months and years are you
enjoying your time with h1z1 what would
you change if you were in charge and no
naked characters is not an option I've
already checked I imagine from
PlayStation grenade it's been a bloody
pleasure I'll see you next time
you
you